boston thank you all for coming out and
showing up i had a great time uh
minneapolis you are up next april 28th
through the 30th get your tickets now at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i want to say thank you as
i do every week for all your support
this show
it can listen i want to say this we had
over a million downloads for the last
three months in a row
audio only all right thank you this show
is growing it continues to grow and it's
because of you thank you for coming out
and supporting me on the road tickets
for all my shows are available at
ryansickler.com all right now the
youtube channel go subscribe the numbers
are climbing over there too but man it
helps us if you're subscribed and uh
it's a free way to help all right
so if you gotta have
more honeydew then there's a patreon
show called the honeydew with you all
that has the absolute wildest stories in
comedy i promise you it's five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you're
getting over a month free and you're
getting the honeydew a day early ad free
at no additional cost all right
and
and you're hearing [ __ ] that i promise
you you're getting nowhere else all
right
uh and if you have a story that has to
be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
so thank you for your support on that
too now that's the biz you know what we
do over here we what do we do we
highlight the low lights y'all these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
uh today i'm very excited to have two
storytellers here one is a repeat guest
and one
is new to do y'all ladies and gentlemen
please welcome dan mancina and anthony
ferraro welcome to the honeydew
gentleman all right
we're
i don't know if we're making podcast
history at least in comedy i don't know
if there's ever been two blind guys on a
podcast
two blind the same room guys in the same
[ __ ] room that's right pleasure
to be here again pleasure pleasure for
you to come back anthony pleasure to
have you here honored to be here um
before we get into what we're gonna get
into feel free to uh plug anything you
guys would like please yeah i would say
uh we have like a co-lab page of me and
him it's four bad eyes across the board
and it's like it's just us messing
around doing funny videos
super fun to watch and then podcasts to
youtube everything for bad eyes yes all
right
anything separately for you anthony or
uh no just that and then i i'm asf
vision across the board mm-hmm
dan the man scene across the board
well it's really good to have you guys
here i was excited when you had this
idea to do this um so
i was asking you guys outside i know dan
you've been on here and we talked about
you you went blind you lost your sight
anthony you said you were born
mm-hmm um so can i ask you a question
yeah you're born blind
and does it get worse as you get older
or if you're born blind is it a set
level and it just maintains through life
does ever get better ever get worse it
depends on the condition i guess so like
some diseases some eye conditions they
get worse over time like in my case and
then some just stay at the level they
were born at
but mine is uh
libra's congenital amaurosis and it's
lca it's called for short and it i was
born with like a little bit of sight you
know where i could see like people like
the outlines of people and no detail or
anything i could see like i could read
really really big print like huge and
then uh as i got older it just slowly
kept deteriorating and now now it's just
like light perception
and like uh sometimes like shadows and
perfect daylight
explain light perception so like i could
see
um
i have a really small sphere so like
it's like
tighter than like looking through two
straws
and then like one eye i can't really see
there's nothing at all it's just like
it's basically a blur where i can just
see if it's light or dark and the other
eye i can make out like colors and stuff
and then uh
like i could see that the sky's blue i
could see that the grass is green but i
can't make out anything of it what
colors do you see most prominent
what's definitely the blue skies um
[Music]
i'd say just lighter colors in general
because like once it gets to a darker
tone like
red and like
red and brown would look the same blue
like black none of those i could tell
apart you know unless they're like neon
and what about you dan what do you see
prominently
nothing i'm total blind now really yeah
were you last time you're here uh-huh
you were all the way at that point i
didn't think you were i thought you
could see like um i thought you said
something about like day and night you
could see you can see yeah
no back like i think four right around
four years ago was when i went like
total blind so i can't tell
light anything like that like i used to
be able to see like
like like you're out in the parking lot
they have skate tricks with a [ __ ]
cane man
you like i used to be able to see like
you shine a flashlight in your eye you
know oh yeah but now none of that so
but i see like weird like flashes and
stuff like that so when you're saying
i'm writing stuff to what he's saying
you're saying it from you remember that
that yeah that sort of you had the same
same yeah going through that yeah yes it
must be similar but like anthony could
never even like
to read
to read anything he would have to blow
like one
single letter at a time up on like a
television screen like a whole
full-length okay to see it just to sit
there because i was so determined to not
be blind like i used to fake it and just
pretend i wasn't blind any way i could i
would have the
the the book under like on this tray and
it was it was called a cctv and it was
this big screen on top and you would put
the book under the tray and it would
blow it up on the screen i'd have like
two letters at a time on this screen
reading so slow and it was just
miserable but i was like nah i could see
can you read braille either of you
that's what i read
yeah i suck at it so
do you okay let me ask it this way when
you learn
the alphabet are you learning first in
braille are you learning by blowing up
the letters on the monitor and reading a
b c like that how are you learning to
read
i learned the visual stuff just at first
because it was a better so like my
parents wanted me to have that reference
point too like a visual like images of
this stuff for when i went blind so i
knew what everything looked like so then
once i hit like
at the time it was like uh i went to
first grade in a school for the blind
and then i just started learning braille
like fully
like print was out of my life
right now with
memory
of letters
can you sit down and from memory draw an
a a b a c all the way through the
alphabet absolutely and it's actually
funny because it's like my handwriting's
like a five-year-old from the last time
i could like see
oh but you can do it huh can you do it
yeah i wrote yeah all the way i think
dana's pretty good handwriting effort i
can be all right and what about numbers
yeah you can write numbers
i can't i can't write like cur the only
thing you're doing cursive is my name
i mean [ __ ] her nobody even does cursive
anymore it's a lost art i swear but you
still sign your name like yeah signature
names yeah
what about um my mom told me you could
just do like an x at the grocery store
yeah
what about like images are there any
images you can draw a flower a car is
there anything that sticks out that you
remember so vividly that you could at
least make it out
for me yeah but the problem is like i
never was able to see fully so
my memory of that
is
just what i was able to see at that time
what would it be
i have no
nothing to compare it to otherwise like
seeing it better but to me like a car
it's a [ __ ] car you know i don't know
it's hard to explain like
i gotta have you draw something i know i
gotta like draw it yeah you're gonna
have to draw it look a car
is that what you'd go for as a car
he said a car so no i'm saying what if
you had to draw anything from memory
right now there was a contest like a
sunset probably a sunset
whatever you won an award for it yeah
one year
oh there was this one night how the [ __ ]
you forget you won an award
my mom's an artist
and she like she you know she started an
art program for the blind when i was
young
in
the school for the blind and
i'll never forget this one night we were
driving home from somewhere and we i
grew up at the beach so we're driving
along ocean avenue and the
moon is like huge right and it's there
it has this like green hue to it because
this the clouds and everything and it's
like foggy and my mom was like anthony
look at that over there like take a
mental note of that like take a picture
of that in your brain and go home and
draw that and like i went home and made
this pastel drawing of like the dark
night sky with this like greenish moon
coming through and then like the clouds
rolling through it just from like my
vision of it and then that and she put
in a contest and ended up like winning
national and like getting like
300
um how do you two know each other
we met we met uh is it a year ago right
yeah it'll be a year ago in june we had
a little skate thing where we got a
bunch of blind people and like other
adaptive skaters together in michigan
you told me about this yeah and we all
were just hanging out and then that's
when we first met
and i was just kind of skating with
anthony and teaching them some stuff i
knew of how to skate blind
is there like a newbie area of that so
that these people aren't [ __ ] running
over each other all the time and hitting
each other and then like a pro level
area or something well what was cool
about that the owner of the park it's an
indoor this huge indoor park and he's
shut your question for a second yeah
what's the insurance policy
i used to get comments like you should
notice
it's skating your own risk but the signs
aren't in braille that's the problem
didn't see the signs
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you two just clicked huh
did you know who dan was before you
became friends with him yeah that's
pretty big deal in your world he's like
the social media big uh blind skate guy
you know he's like the goat yeah he is i
know
but no tony blind skating over here i
didn't know how big he was i didn't know
anthony very much okay and like his tick
tock is huge oh yeah is that right and
now he's like youtube's yeah he just got
his creator award for 100k youtube and
all that sent me four
so youtube i got uh like 100 000
subscribers a couple months ago they
sent me an award i was pumped it wasn't
in braille or anything but i didn't
really care that much but all these
people online were like oh they should
send you a braille one that's kind of
messed up like billion dollar
corporation you know and then all of a
sudden i got an email saying we're so
sorry we'll send you one in braille
so i'm real pumped right this awards
coming
get in the mail open it on camera like
doing a live unboxing like video for it
and
i opened it i feel the braille it's
micro braille like you can't make
braille this small i don't know how they
did it was like white out print like
just on the uh thing and i go to read
the braille and as i read it the braille
wipes off with my fingers
on camera i'm like
oh [ __ ] and like this video ends up
getting like 14 million jews right
so
i'm like good i'm like oh man like d
monetizing
right they can't even braille
wiped it off there's some grease
we are so sorry like we're overnighting
you a new one
they sent a brand new one overnight i
get the big box this time i'm pumped
during this box i go i'm doing i'm like
oh they sent a new one like making the
video and then open it the braille is
perfect except there's one space in my
last name so like f-e-r-r-a space ro but
i was like whatever that's sick you know
like the braille is on there i can read
it it's perfect and then my girl is like
my wife kelly she's like
oh [ __ ] and i'm like what and she's like
they left out the last n in your uh name
in your first name and i was like
anthoi
oh i do i couldn't believe i was like
i'm going to hang this thing up in my
office and i they anthony i
[Music]
but they got it right and i was pumped
it was all right
on youtube for getting it right
um
all right so you guys meet a year ago
and now you uh buddy up you're going
around doing [ __ ] together all right
yeah i was getting sick of doing stuff
solo i was getting burnt down on it i
was like i need to like i just want to
partner with somebody and like this
would be more fun you know yeah you guys
seem like you and then me and you
connect well that's perfect um all right
so you both sent some some stories
um i'm going to just bounce back and
forth off your list so i do want to do
this because damn we we touched on last
time
your thumb and then we never got to it
you're right and fans were well you
never got to the [ __ ] thumb cut my
thumb let's do your [ __ ] thumb
all right when i was this is i lived in
uh can i see it
yeah
there's like it's like half right so
it's right above the nail he's a blind
dancer
man you would a blind guy would cut his
thumb off i say that well i was cited
this time when i was this when i was a
little i was seven years old
i always
me and anthony always joke because we do
the adaptive skate contest and i say i'm
blind and amputee too yeah you should i
mean is that technically an answer yes
is
i can't throw a football man
yeah
oh man
[Music]
when i was seven i used to live uh
warren on the border warren east detroit
and my mom used to run at the high
school there okay and in the middle of
the track there was like some football
stuff so i think it's called the fumble
drill
it's like two arches and
on the arms of the arches there's like
rubber arms that stick out so you like
run through it i guess i don't know i
never played football does that make
sense yeah you never know what it's
called supposed to cover the ball and
run through it yeah yeah it's like it's
like a turn style there's a bunch of
them on there yeah exactly exactly and
uh
i was there with one two of my brothers
and one of their friends
and uh we're just like climbing on it i
was seven years old so we're just
playing on this thing and my buddy's
laying across my brother's buddy's
laying across the top row of them and
i'm climbing up the side so when he was
laying on the top one of the arms was
pushed down and open so the spring
didn't have a cap on it and it was like
exposed right so my thumb went in that
little spring
and right at the same time he slipped
down so it just came up and like
literally squished my thumb oh and i
didn't i didn't even know
like i didn't feel it at first right
he's just laying on the ground and blood
drops on his chest and he's like looked
up he's like dude and then we realized
my thumb's in here
so they gotta grab it pull it open and i
pull my thumb out and it's hanging by
like a little piece of skin yeah just
like mashed
and they're like oh [ __ ] i go to i run
to my first brother and he's [ __ ]
freaks out he starts screaming damn cut
his thumb off dan cut his thumb off just
like like a chicken with his head cut
off i'm like all right he's useless so i
remember seven yeah so i'm going to my
next brother it's my daughter's age
right now
my mom was probably like on the other
half of the track or something like that
go to my next brother and he's like
squinting he's like what the [ __ ] he's
like oh [ __ ] and he took me to my mom
and i don't remember much after this i
know there was a dude in the parking lot
who just was like [ __ ] pale-faced and
looked and like do you have a car my
mom's like yeah and he just bounced he
was out of there
okay
yeah he's like
like i don't have to help these and then
i remember driving his old aerostar van
i was sitting in the front with like a
my mom had like a birthday card or
something i had under my hand it's just
like dripping
and uh
drive down the street was a uh what is
it like a fire station
are you crying are you [ __ ] screaming
i'm in complete shock i don't i don't
remember feeling any pain at all when i
think back so i go
knock on the door and they come out like
oh [ __ ] i just remember him wrapping it
with gauze and it was like a beehive on
my hand this giant ball of gauze and
they put me in an ambulance
and then what else do i remember being
in the ambulance is coming like in and
out of consciousness
and i guess like
i guess i was like in really bad shock
where i was like passing out and losing
all this blood where like i almost died
and [ __ ] like that
and then they took me to the hospital
and i remember much after that just
being laid up in the hospital and
i know i missed the rest of the school
year did school from home a long time i
got straight a's i got straight a's i
remember that
and then all kinds of like toys aladdin
on vhs [ __ ]
that's what sticks out yeah that little
dumb car aladdin
and then
they tried to sew it back on so is that
part nail right there that's just where
the bone is
that's like where the bone would be
that's a what that's like where the bone
would be
right so it's kind of like
weirdly scam is it toughened up now like
it's not this
can you use it as a weapon
it's really sensitive because
i was out here he was skating and he got
like he fell and next time i saw him he
had a band-aid on his um and he's like i
hate when i hurt my um dude it's so
annoying um
because i go to fall i go to put my
thumb down and it just gouges the top
what's the
thing you miss most with that little
piece of thumb that what what what do
you what annoys you the most
nothing really i don't remember you
don't need that you don't i really don't
need that i can do everything because it
was right above that joint if it would
have been below that joint we had to
take the whole thing off oh is that
right and i would have looked real goofy
but a lot of people don't notice it
until like i'm actually doing something
right up to them
um okay anthony we have uh smashing my
penis over here
i was four years old
and i'll never forget this we had a
bathroom like in the living room right
so everyone's chilling in the living
room we're having people over
at my parents house and
i go to the bathroom it's one of those
times where you have to like you know
you're short so you're really little and
i would like rest my dick on the toilet
on like the the rim the rim that's what
i was like
nasty right
i'll never leave home without those now
squatty potty's the best they need to
make a travel they do have one yeah it's
called a poor disquality it folds it
comes in a bag and it folds up yeah oh
yeah i'm gonna get that for my trip it's
nice so my parents just got this nice
new like
one of those heavy like ceramic toilet
seats they just bought it and it had a
lady that sold it to him they bought it
brand new from the store and it had a
crack in it no one knew and i had both
seats up while i'm paying and all sudden
both seats just smashed down on my dick
and
i've never heard my dick right now i
started screaming so loud like bloody
murder i was so little and
run out of the door there's literally
blood squirting out of the like top of
my dick and i'm screaming everyone's
like freaking out like what the heck
and the next thing i know is like waking
up in the hospital and like just taking
that gross medicine that tastes like
bubble gum like the liquid [ __ ] and i
had to do that for like a couple weeks
and then i did i remember i could barely
pee without it i couldn't pee without
hurting at all it burnt so bad because
it got a separate hole like it made a
second hole
like it's pierced it pierced
and then
that had to heal but every time i pee it
would like it would burn so bad i
remember somebody shoot out of that
whole like i don't remember
a little crooked just the tiniest [ __ ]
like not even a lot at all where you
notice your wreath is right that's the
tip
it's like when i bite on straws and
floss with them and squeeze them down
so
and then it was like we had this huge
lawsuit with the company yeah dude it
was bad because they sold us a broken
toilet seat and it smashed my dick and
what so did you win we won would you win
uh i think it was like
like some
it wasn't even that much money but free
toilet seats for life yeah yeah you know
no and i remember like whenever i was
like at the time after all this was like
getting sudden i was like probably seven
once the loss said [ __ ] takes forever or
whatever and
sitting in the courtroom i'll never
forget the judge says my dad like
you know once he's 18 i can't tell him
what to like he can do whatever he wants
with this uh money like if he wants to
buy a car he could buy a car and i
remember sitting there like don't think
he's gonna be able to draw one i could
buy a car and then my dad goes uh with
all due respect you're on i don't think
my kid's buying a car
ended up buying my wife's engagement
ring he saved it i saved him my whole
life i was like i'm either buying that
dick money yeah i might dick money dude
that's what i call it i got my dick
money and i see i was like i'm either
buying an engagement ring with this or
buying a down payment on a house and i
got the engagement right it's his dick
got his wife
bro how about that no i just remember
saving that i was like about that can't
spend it you're [ __ ] you're you're
hurt dick just paid for forever that's
beautiful that's beautiful
dude i had a
i had a kidney stone one time oh i know
man i'm with you on that they have
biggest fears oh they pulver
they put a stint in them oh no god
forbid and every time i peed it would be
like someone twisted my [ __ ] kidney
and then i go through like they
pulverized it do all this stuff and to
take the stint out i'm like wide awake
it's like in a regular
like hospital or not a hospital like an
office
lays me down on this table like a barber
chair leaning back and he goes with this
scope and he goes right through my dick
hole like right in front of me and i'm
just sitting there like dude what is
happening
didn't hurt that much but it was just
like the most awkward is that a capital
what's that called
a capillator is that what they put in
your pee hole
after you get like surgery or something
oh a catheter
yeah yeah that dude i'll never i got
hemorrhoid surgery
you did what the hell happened
so i do judo for the like training for
the paralympics yeah tell us about that
as well please it's just other blind
people uh from all around the world
fighting like uh in judo and you go
around the uh world they're competing at
different like
competitions to get points to make it to
the paralympics where are you ranked uh
i was ranked top 20 all right and then
in the world and then i like was so
close to making it to 2021 in tokyo and
then i tore my groin like right before
it happened yeah it sucked
but you think you can get a gold
no no
bro you think you could medal i think i
can medal this time
silver bronze i'm gonna get gold this
time all right then you do think you can
how do you wear your hair when you judo
i get it braided tight like yeah
all right but i threw someone in judo
like in germany i'll never forget it
like deadlifted this guy off the ground
and i threw my back out and then i was
having all this problem like
constipation and [ __ ] like because it
was the time difference and traveling
and then for months i ignored it like
just i didn't even know what hemorrhoids
were and then one day it got so bad
where am i i just thought like i was
wiping too aggressive or something like
my ass was just itchy
and uh
one day it got so bad where i couldn't
like walk and i was like this is really
bad i went to all these different
doctors who just kept telling me i had
hemorrhoids so gave me the cream and
then finally i went to a specialist and
he's like
did like a whole exam like the
examination everything got my first
digital and i was like
it's the worst thing ever and uh
the guy is like i don't know how you're
walking you have like a fissure and like
multiple hemorrhoids and like
immediately put me into surgery and then
uh where was i going oh right when i got
out of school yeah no right
right when i got out of surgery i'm
never forgetting i no one said anything
about this but i was like so scared they
were gonna put something in my pee hole
and i'm like so delusional from the
fentanyl and everything like whatever
they give you for the anesthesia i wake
up at a surgery where they're rolling
you out and you're still in and out and
i'm like they're like you're out like
everything's good i'm like do not put a
catheter in me like i woke up like real
quick and like said that to her
like no one's gonna do that
don't touch my dick i'm traumatized from
when i smash i have penis trauma when
you go in with the catheter make sure
you go in the right hole dude make sure
you go on the front one for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers i know i
took spanish from 8th through 11th grade
and i've said it before i wasn't even
good with english
but now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world you all know i've been taking
my espanol and it's going muy bueno all
right the thing i really like about it
is you get to speak you get to hear it
from a male and a female you get to hear
the accents the inflections then you
have to speak back and say it properly
so that you can pass on and they do
these little bite size
chunks where you're constantly you know
repeating and redoing things that's for
me is the best way to learn other
language learning apps use ai for their
lesson plans but babel lessons were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus it comes
with a 20-day money-back guarantee start
your new language learning journey today
with babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com use my promo code
honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babel language for life
mellower vibes or a drop or a toke away
with dad grass they'll take it back to a
time when music was on vinyl delta was
an airline and hipsters were a style of
genes sit back light up and chill out
the old-fashioned way dad grass is legal
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and mellows your mind their 100
organic pre-roll joints are very low in
thc and high in cbd so you can enjoy the
effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head want the toke without the smoke
daggrass also has a cbd tincture made
with the same high quality hemp it's
easy to dose and the effects come on
smooth chill out without getting stoned
it's like having a glass of wine not the
whole bottle all dagg grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the u.s whether you're looking for a new
buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite dag grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now daggrass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's
slash
dadgrass.com
now let's get back to the do um okay dan
i want to hear i'm looking at your list
over here i want to hear this uh lax
story this restroom in lax
this is when i had a little that's when
i had a like some site so i wasn't using
a cane
and i'm
leaving lax can i ask you
just for a moment and maybe you can
answer this too anthony when were you
not using a can at that point because
you were fighting it and just were like
i can do this was it pride was it
for me it was never pride i had i just
had like
like i had pretty like really good
vision yeah you know like my central
vision was still good like i used to
work at a deli and slice meat you know i
mean one of those like [ __ ] slices
[ __ ] yeah as a like a legally blind
person
because like central vision's still good
but my peripherals all gone
so like i could always navigate at that
point i could navigate fine right you
kill her on them center cuts man yeah
[Laughter]
so yes like but i had trouble reading
like signs and stuff i couldn't see i
couldn't see any signs in the airport
but i had it like mapped out pretty good
because i'd been there a million times
i'm going to the bathroom
and at this point like the men's and the
ladies were right next to it's like
right where you can go into the delta
lounge right there you see two bathrooms
and i go and i look at the sign and in
my head i saw the men's logo
so i go in there and i go in the stall
and i'm taking a [ __ ] and i'm sitting
there and then i hear like ladies voices
i'm like oh [ __ ] and i started thinking
back like yeah i didn't see any stall or
any uh urinals in here yeah like oh my
god i'm in the [ __ ] woman's bathroom
right now
and no cane you could at least
underneath or something exactly
and this is this is pretty [ __ ]
anyone could use the bathroom yeah yeah
yeah you're right
you're right
i was like [ __ ] how am i gonna go
i just [ __ ] finished
i open the door and i beeline it
straight to the exit and there's two
ladies looking they're both just staring
at the mirror like doing their makeup
didn't even look at me or glanced and
walked right past them and left and went
to the men's and washed my [ __ ] hands
but that feeling of like i was like damn
i [ __ ] up you know what i mean like
yeah
have you ever [ __ ] up like that in any
other situation oh yeah this before
you're asking me night yeah yeah
i'll do the river storm
the what the river story is too this is
when i wasn't using a cane too
and i'm up north michigan
and this is like end of april so
snow has just thawed and we're staying
on this
like nice campsite right next to this
river and the river has a big bank
that's about like
above head so it's gotta be like seven
eight feet tall and we're sitting by the
fire
like getting just like hammer all you do
is drink up there so i'm like [ __ ]
three sheets to the wind
i leave fires i gotta go piss start
walking in the woods walking walking
right step left step and then [ __ ]
nothing
drop straight to the river
and like in the [ __ ] river can you
swim yeah i can swim but it was like
i [ __ ] i barely remember like how i
how i felt i just remembered no earth
underneath me
and then popping out of the water
all my friends heard it so they come
running over and like i look up there's
like headlamps just staring down at me
gotta reach up and they pulled me out
but that was the first time where i was
i was actually really pissed after that
because i was like dude
you can really like get hurt if you're
not paying attention and not having a
cane and it really [ __ ] with me
mentally of like
having to start using a [ __ ] cane and
like really think about
how you're walking and navigating and
stuff like that because
yeah you know hit your head and [ __ ]
float away you're gone or something gone
water is like freezing water yeah but
yeah holy [ __ ] just boom into a river
you just got baptized bro baptized dude
i had one way thought i was falling in
the mississippi river
yeah i was so scared like i've never
been more
please like i was so happy to hit the
ground i was like oh thank god but i was
riding a scooter in new orleans like on
this path
with my my girl was right behind me and
she's right here
yeah electric one no no
just a freaking uh razor razor scooter
and like she's got she's filming behind
me and i'm just like whipping down this
path
and i know that the river is like a 30
foot drop off on my right but i don't
know anything else between that and next
thing i know i'm i'm riding right and i
always hear oh [ __ ] and like i'm going
over the front handlebars of the scooter
and i'm going through the air and in air
i think i'm falling into the mississippi
river
dude i'm [ __ ] i'm not gonna be able to
make it out because it's like a 30 foot
like to get up and it's this current is
so strong and this is disgusting right
here like i was and then i hit the
ground and i was just you the biggest
smile on my face like in the video
it was thought you were gonna get it
truly baptizing the muddy water what let
me ask you this what's the most
frustrating thing about
not having vision
and
just like some of the little things like
what annoys you what's a what's a daily
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah like
sometimes when you uh
if you're looking for something and you
know it's like in this general area and
you've looked like all around this area
feeling like hands and knees
and then someone comes in with sight and
they're like oh it's right here and you
were just like an inch away from finding
it yeah you're spending five minutes
through your life
yeah
so these little things just
they build up so much time in your day
and then
me i'm like so over it sometimes where
i'm just like trying to run through it
everything so i'm like you know [ __ ] it
i'm just like running through my house
and [ __ ] and then something's moved up
or i'll like misjudge where something
was like from my memory and just nail my
head or my shin and i'm like it's such
[ __ ] you know like i'll freak out
sometimes where i'm like i could ride a
skateboard i could like you know
do jude i like grappling i could do all
these things and like can't [ __ ] see
a damn wall in front of my face you know
and that should really frustrate
speaking of which watch your heads on
the way down the stairs here at the
studio there's a metal bar across the
top
you will crack that [ __ ] from
standing up too straight
um all right let me ask you this
is there a silver lining it would what
would you say is if you had to find a
positive about it what would you say is
is
something that's good about it i think
and maybe i'm asking it the wrong way
that's great do you know what i'm saying
kind of a double-edged sword for me
because
at some points people are overly helpful
for you like trying to help you with
every little thing but then at the same
time it's like
people
really are nice and you realize like
there's a lot of good people who like
are generally they're just looking out
for you you know what i mean walking
down the street you have random people
come up to you like hey man you need
help or anything like that
and like i think that's super positive
because people are like
not everybody's mean you know what i
mean right not everybody's like
[ __ ]
trying to get you you know what i mean
not coming out for you which seems like
that's how the world's painted more and
more lately so i'm not waiting in
airport lines not waiting in there
for me like two when because i was born
blind so like i was never really able to
see people and like what everyone looked
like and i think that really helped me
in terms of not judging people off at
first glance and like i actually had to
get to know someone for their
personality and judge them off that and
that like helped me really get to
connect with people a lot more growing
up i like that
let me ask you this without sight not
being able to see people
within the blind community
is there racism
is there oh that's interesting ah
i just got it that is yeah i'm sure
there's definitely amongst
you know it's like in any
community
okay so yeah i haven't witnessed you
haven't firsthand i mean i don't we
don't know that there's some really
proud
blind people that are like anti-sighted
people
if that's what you mean too or no
the blind people that can't see it all
and then the people that could see a
little i oh okay so that's the next
thing i want to ask you among the blind
people then
if not racism what is the where is the
the disconnect where the there's some
people who are super proud to be blind
yeah and like they don't want braille on
money they don't want anything changed
in this world because they're they're
confident
in their abilities and we don't need any
assistance okay and then there's just
other people who are just like yeah put
[ __ ] braille on money yeah like
that'd be chill and that we need like
more
equality yeah [ __ ] do you know if
you're holding a five or a 10 or a 20.
how do you do these little scanners
there's an app on the phone you can scan
it'll tell you but what about before
that
um you can get a free
uh reader from the government they came
out with yeah you just apply and they
send it to you and you just like put the
corner of the bill in it and it'll tell
you what currency it is i see but and
then you just fold it a certain way you
know 20 is like a hot dog
fives like this
so you can have it organized
but now i just use the app on the phone
if i ever need to know okay you just
scan it tells you in like real time what
it is all right so now how dependent are
you guys on technology these days
oh super yeah the phone yeah it's nice
especially once touched like touch
screen yeah did you have a flip phone
yeah i had a flip phone for the longest
time and wouldn't change like that
so there's a lot of people with sight to
do that too by the way yeah i had like
memory i i would have the whole phone
memorized like every menu how many
clicks down in that menu to get to the
next one like even my change is really
what it was it was changed yeah and then
learning that whole new thing but once
you do it's like all right
yeah you're fine
and it's
that most time technology's there to
help you know it's huge getting rides
uber and all that stuff
yeah uber that opened like a whole new
world um
tell me sometime that some of you knew
you caught someone trying to rip you off
go first uh dan
someone's trying to rip me off i don't
think i'm scamming
you none of that you haven't had that
now that i know of yeah how about you i
recognize
i was at a glass shop
uh like a smoke shop thing i was looking
at like something
and i was asking the guy the price and
he was like this is actually in l.a like
last month and i was asking the guy the
price
and he's like oh it's 180 and i was like
oh that's like the best you can do
and i was like you know it looked like i
was about to turn around and i had my
cane and everything i'm in there by
myself
and uh the guy's like you know what i
could do 140 plus tax for you man for
like for you i could do that and i'm
like oh sick like the guy's kind of
hooking it up you know so i'm like
all right whatever and i got it
go out to the car and i'm like yeah he
hooked it up like we said like he
brought it down to 140 my wife looks at
she's like the sticker price is 140.
i thought she was gonna say seven
but still it was so that [ __ ] me up so
bad because he was pissed i was dude i
called him crying like i was raped like
so mad and i was like
i couldn't believe i was like how many
[ __ ] times has this happened to me in
my life that i don't even know about
like i just went in there trying to be
like independent this [ __ ] guy is
scamming me and like
you know you can say [ __ ] honestly i
know i know but like i was just so
pissed i was like i can't believe it and
it made me like for like 10 minutes lose
all hope and humanity like i just gave
up for a minute you know and i was like
get over yourself so then what what
brings it back for you then he went back
in though and [ __ ] told the dude did
you yeah for you i was like yo it's real
messed up you're lying to blind people
like acting like you're hooking him up
and not doing like and doing that and
he's he had nothing to say didn't say
anything that's you take that can you
knock all that glass
[ __ ] out of the way you know that rage
in your mind you could see yourself
doing something like no
yeah um it's just a matter of like you
gotta keep going like you can't give up
though it's like you can't you can't let
that sit in your house how old are you
anthony 27 uh about yeah 27 what about
you dan 34 okay
um
anthony tell me about your mom's brain
injury
oh yeah um
so i was living in california at the
time but i was home for like christmas
and all that and my brother had just
passed away
what happened to your brother he was 27
and he
he died in his sleep geez yeah it was
like
one night of like partying went wrong
but like not even like serious partying
or anything like that it was like
some [ __ ] like in the [ __ ] you know like
stuff was messed with or something
gotcha
but uh
that happened and then i was home for
christmas and i'm at my buddy's house
like after new year's and stuff
about to go out to the bar
and
i was gonna go to the bar with all my
buddies and not come home for a while
something was like you gotta get home
like in me i was it was so strong and
i've never felt this before in my entire
life but it was like get the [ __ ] home
now
and i was like what is going on you know
and it was so strong that i looked at my
one friend and i was like dude you gotta
give me a ride home right now
so
my buddy only lives like five minutes
from my parents house and we get in the
car
start driving to my parents house and
all of a sudden we get pulled over by a
cop
yeah
a cop pulls us over
calls back up
two cops are there two cop cars for two
just two we're like 20 years old at this
point
and
sitting there the cops like ask us all
these questions you know do you have
anything in the car ended up making us
get out of the car searching us and all
this stuff we had nothing like nothing
we weren't lying about anything
get to my house
go downstairs like we have a jam room in
the basement where we play music and
stuff and we go downstairs and at the
bottom of the stairs i run into a body
and my mom i
like hear like this breathing and my
body's like oh my god oh my god
and i reached down and it's my mom like
unconscious in a pool of blood jesus did
you know it was your mom right away is
that the only person yeah he because he
said your mom
and
i like picked picked her i went on
autopilot like if i was thinking
straight i would have freaked out i
literally picked her up ran upstairs
like in a like cradle you know like
cradling her and then put her on the
chair started like dabbing her face with
a towel because she hit her head and
split it open when she fell down the
stairs
and
my buddies like doing everything i asked
like get me all the stuff and then are
you just feeling blood and everything
like i have blood on my face like all
over me it was so
it was really scary like if i was
thinking
about what was going on i literally
would have lost it i wouldn't be able to
control myself and
i call the ambulance i tell them what's
going on they come
and while i'm waiting for the ambulance
all of a sudden my mom i hear like
you know she's making this sound where
she's like
like barely breathing and i'm like at
this point i'm almost yelling and i'm
like come on mom like why like why did
this happen like why like so confused
and then all of a sudden i hear her stop
breathing and i like freaked out and
then like gave her this little shake and
hear like
like breath go back into her and then my
buddy's there the whole time and then
the ambulance gets there
and she gets in the ambulance and i'm
still at my house with my buddy and all
of a sudden like reality hits me and i
just start like throwing up and like
losing my [ __ ]
and then my like my buddy's dad had to
come over he's emt to like clean up the
pool of blood in my basement and then my
mom was in a coma for like
two months like i couldn't even go to
the hospital for the first like a couple
weeks or like week or so because i was
so terrified
and when i got there i like my mom was
hooked up to all these machines and she
was like her hands were super swollen
and i remember just like
my knees buckled and i fainted like i
was yeah i was so shocked you walk in
the ho in the room and all you hear are
just like machines machines and my mom's
on this machine and i can't i can't see
what's going on either so i'm like
making all these things up in my mind
and it's like
and then like
the doctor told us she like doctor sat
me down and said it would take her like
years and years before she'd be able to
do anything again like you know whatever
and
within like a couple like so like a
month later my mom's like she's awake
and stuff she can't talk cause like her
whole like
all this like all the throw and
everything for some reason the way she
was hit and like
how everything happened and she was in
the coma she couldn't talk
and she was just trying to rip the
things off her and they had to put those
like
those like glove things on her head and
[ __ ] and like i was like oh man and it
was just like
it was a lot and then like by the time
she was coming too
like starting to talk and stuff and then
in the rehab and stuff my mom was like
that's when i knew she was coming back
it's like they're like feeding her food
and she's like is this organic
and then my uncle would be like visiting
like we're all there and she my mom's
brother she's one of 13 kids so like
they're all there you know and like
uh my my uncle's there she goes leo
let's let's go get everyone chinese food
real quick and she would like try
anything she could do to like get
everyone to get her out of there and she
would like would bribe the nurses she'd
be like i'll give you 150 bucks to drive
me home right now
and then she just like made him like it
was literally a miracle the recovery she
made and how long was she in the coma
for i want to say a month and a half man
you ever talk to her about it like
anything
this is a crazy part yeah this is
intense this is really intense when my
mom was in the coma
she said that
she was like on this cliff like on the
side of it like climbing it and she just
kept climbing up and climbing up and
wanted to get to the top so bad and
multiple times she would feel something
grab her from the back and like pull her
away from the top and like pull her back
down and it was my brother saying he
literally she heard his voice and you'd
be like mom it's not your time you've
got to stay and literally have multiple
times and she said one time she got her
hand to the top and like
could like feel this amazing thing she
was about to get to and then pulled back
and then finally like woke up wow and it
was your brother's voice specifically um
yeah
how's he feel about that
it was a brother that passed away oh
it's not your time get the [ __ ] out of
here it's like it gives you goosebumps
talking about holy [ __ ] that's why oh so
he i thought of it the other way when
you first told me that story she was
like
climbing to like
to the pearl x yeah to like
and your brother was pulling her back
yeah
wow damn that is nuts and my mom's here
still and like they said like you know
if i missed it like 10 minutes later 20
minutes later she could have died mm-hmm
and those cops
could have stopped
that's a great story
um
tell me what's mental hospital anthony
what is that
it was when i was 18 years old and i was
like
i'd like so i got a bad concussion in
college
um
this was a separate concussion just
wrestling i got like slammed on my head
and then sophomore year college and then
i was like well i'm not here wrestling
and it's kind of what i came here for
and then started being like college uh
tcn the college of new jersey
and
used to be trend state and then uh
i was
stopped going to school after my like
one semester like my grades were good
and everything i just like didn't know
what i wanted to do and i was so lost
and confused you know that point in your
life it's like when everyone is but uh
i just like was lashing out so pissed at
everything and like you know
angry at like i get angry at my parents
for nothing and like
just so like this angry kid like i don't
know what was wrong with me and then
i finally like lashed out so much it was
just like i think i did it as like
almost like thinking i was getting at my
parents in a way but like really it was
just [ __ ] me up like i was like i'm
just going to go to the mental hospital
you know one of those things like
yourself
check myself you checked yourself
checked myself in how old are you i was
18. okay so you can do that yeah okay
and i checked myself in
thinking like i'm just gonna chill here
for a couple days everything's gonna
blow over you know like
[ __ ] they start pumping you with all
these drugs and [ __ ] and like giving you
like all these medications hold up let's
let's let's not jump over enrollment and
everything else here you
you checked yourself in and what do they
say to you when you get there i just mad
willfully take you
so they put me in the the
uh like room where they start
questioning you right
and it was going on for like hours how
many people were talking to you i think
it was like three different people
really and it's going for hours yeah
this was going on for a long time
and they're asking all these things and
i'm just like
no i just
i just want to be here like type of
thing like this angry ass remember any
questions we like answering honestly
were you trying to get in i think i was
just trying to get in and i was just
like
i i need to be here like i don't
i i don't feel safe for myself because
i'm losing my [ __ ] right now type of
thing like and
and my parents were trying everything
they could do to like not let this
happen are they showing you spot charts
you're like
i can't see that i don't know it's like
all this [ __ ] and i remember finally
like getting checked in right and like
going up there and it was like
almost this feeling of like
what the [ __ ] did i just do
it's like reality
because you know that's what i want to
know are you now like a ward of the
state you can't [ __ ] leave yeah so
i'm locked in there for like
for real
they have to examine you
they have to um
just like
basically cleared the lead yeah cleared
to leave
and i was like okay and
i
i remember my stipulation i was like i'm
not [ __ ] going in there unless i can
bring my guitar though and i made them
let me bring my guitar like an acoustic
guitar that they had locked in the
closet and like i'd asked to be able to
play
and would they let you sometimes i'll
never forget so it was like
dude in there was such a
it was like you're
feel like you're a zombie and around a
bunch of zombies because you're in this
room there's no fresh air it's like you
have separate bedrooms off to the side
and it's just like a
living room type area where everyone
hangs out there's like
little games or something they might let
you play and then you get like an hour
of tv time or something they go to all
these like
meetings to like talk about it like
therapy
which therapy was good because that
helped me talk [ __ ] out
but then
finally i'm like i gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here you know it was like two
days later
days i can't i'm scared i was i had
doctors coming and like talking to me
and
i was like what did i do man and then
finally um i'll never forget i had it
was like everyone's like real down in
there you know it's like this vibe dude
it's like they make it that way almost
it's like supposed to be and like
nothing's happening we're trying to keep
everybody just calm and very very stoic
you know and uneventful
and i started playing my guitar one day
i had
the person that wouldn't even talk to
you like [ __ ] face like not like [ __ ]
angry green in the corner you know like
mad at the world
i had everybody dancing and like singing
in the mental hospital
i had the nurses
i had the nurses dancing dude it got to
the point where i was like the nurses
were almost like why are you here
because like the nurse one nurse was
from jamaica she would do my hair every
morning like we would just sit and talk
about life and like and at one point i
started losing you know i was like i
really gotta get out of here and then
finally like how many months are you in
at this point now no it's just three
days oh days yeah three days and then
finally it's over and i get out and like
i have to go to outpatient you know
where you go to like just therapy
groups or whatever like once a week or
twice a week
and then i started like
i took the the medication like an
antidepressant and it started like
it started like really messing with me i
think like i started getting these like
electric shocks through my body and all
this stuff and then they started giving
me different ones to try and then one
day i passed out in the shower i'll
never forget it and i never pass out i
was just taking a shower next thing i'm
waking up on the ground and it freaked
me the [ __ ] out like i was so terrified
and i went to the doctor and i was like
this happened and he's like oh you have
panic disorder let me give you another
pill for us yeah right and i remember
standing up and be like is that what you
do like i was so i i like i was like
this is so bad man
i fired a doctor before for that [ __ ]
literally had this clarity i like went
off on him saying all this stuff but in
a very calm manner like very um
respect not respectful actually but like
very not like yelling not raising my
voice yeah professional [ __ ] exactly and
uh i told him off and he's like get the
[ __ ] out of my office he said that yeah
because i was like and you're doing all
that just so you can drive that bmw
outside that was my final statement
is it get the [ __ ] out of my office and
uh
that day i like i don't recommend this
but like i called turkey from everything
and like i you know through
holistic ways and stuff got off that
stuff and like
thankfully through that journey i
learned so much about myself and like
you know
really like therapy helps and talking to
people health and [ __ ] like that's all i
needed to do i was like denying therapy
for so long that i just need to like
talk my [ __ ] out of like dude i grew up
never had sight like real sight so like
i was angry about this [ __ ] you know and
like not being a normal kid like growing
up and just wanting to be normal so bad
and
you know finding all that out through
that [ __ ] it really
it was a shitty way to get there but i
got there you know
good for you man yeah
yeah i couldn't imagine being it was
born blind having it yeah having just
that
division between you and just your
everyone like as a kid in school you
know it's such a
big part of who you are and who you
become and then feeling like divided
from everybody it would be like i was
the blind shitty way to grow up when
you're among
your students and peers at a the school
for the blind and you're not the blind
kid what is life like
then
so that was pretty chill but the thing
is i was always going back home like so
i went to school in philly is it i'm
sorry to interrupt but is that a place
you can live
no oh okay commute yes our commute every
day from philadelphia from new jersey to
philadelphia and back so it was like a
two-hour commute i go to school buster
[ __ ] place to another ball buster
please yeah yeah isn't that the one he
had to fight to yeah there was a whole
course litigation to get him into this
school well to get me transportation to
the school because the state didn't want
to provide that so me and my mom lived
in an apartment in philly
i'm the youngest of five and like she
literally went to got this apartment in
philly we stayed there for during the
week so i can go to school and then went
back home on the weekends for like two
years while that went on
and then uh
where was i going with this
uh being
in school with other blocks oh yeah it's
just
so when you're
when you go once i made that transfer
too from like so seventh grade i went
from the blind school to the regular
school like public school in my town in
new jersey so i like knew some people
but i was also the only blind person
that that school's really ever seen
and i would like
put my braille books on my lap under the
desk to like act like you know like i'm
not reading braille like this should say
i would get handouts and i'd be
scribbling on the handouts with a pen
like acting like i'm filling [ __ ] out
like just so i can look normal
just rotate it for you
one time
like it's upside down i was like oh no
i was just that anxiety as a kid just
it's like crippling
and then one time i went to a dance
finally in seventh grade i'm in the
public school in my town like i could go
to the dance all the girls are there
like you know it's everyone goes this
huge thing because all the district like
five different towns go to this dance
and i'm like i can't wait i get i'm in
line for the dance i don't have my cane
because i hate being blind i'm trying
not to be blind and all my friends go in
and then i get pulled to the side in a
classroom with a police officer and a
teacher saying your eyes are [ __ ] up
what's wrong with you what drugs are you
on asking me all this [ __ ] and i was so
scarred from that i was like i'm blind
and they were like yeah right and like
had to call my parents to confirm
and then let me into the dance and then
then for all through high school after
that even like seventh eighth grade high
school i hated school dances i was like
terrified to go just because of that and
like ruined it for you it ruined it
but you also struggle like when you're
born blind i've
i've related to like when you lose
someone you have you ever lost someone
yeah that's why we got a show here bro
yeah his whole life has been lost
exactly
no but um so like you know that feeling
though where like you would have you
ever driven yourself crazy about someone
really close that all you want to do is
bring them back yeah and like it's
it you could sit there and that feeling
alone could probably drive you insane if
you let it like take over
that is like the feeling of wanting to
see perfectly like just one day like two
minutes what does that look like and it
could drive you insane and it's like you
just have to like
live keep living let me ask you this
this is a weird feeling first of all two
questions i guess do you feel that there
will be a technology before we're gone
where you'll be able to see
the way
you know 2020
do you is that in your world right now
do you know of technology is there
something coming is there anything
that's beneficial this
uh and and also
what about vr have you guys dabbled in
vr at all is there anything for the
blind that you could see or anything
like that or push it into a reality
world because you would have to have
something
that would be linked directly
excuse me
it would have to be linked directly to
your brain because your eyes aren't
processing anything you know
there's nothing i mean there's something
called the argus things like the argus 2
chip now which is an implant which does
signal to the brain and you can
see things like uh
if you put like a strand of lights
around a door frame or something like
that you could tell where that door
frame is i see
um but
i don't even think that would i don't
think that would work for me because i
think you still need
like your retina attached or something
like that
um
and there's no like no i mean i think
there is nothing [ __ ] about [ __ ] but is
there there's no cadaver surgery where
they could can't reattach your retinas
or even put eyes into somebody is that
possible if the nerve is dead it's over
it's over yeah like the rest is detached
yeah that retina's
super like just we don't have the
technology to know how to connect that
retina and signal to the brain there's
crazy breakthroughs now though with
different like eye conditions that
they're getting like gene therapy like
injecting
like the needle in your eye and then
you're able to read a couple more lines
on the chart
but with that like even my eye condition
alone it has like a thousand different
types of genes
and each
each leaver's eye condition like my eye
condition
each one could be a different gene so
you have to have that specific gene for
that specific gene therapy so they need
like thousands of cures all right one
eye condition i'm gonna ask you each the
same question i'll go with you first dan
you get 24 hours of perfect sight what
do you do with it
man i go to the mountains i love the
mountains mountains with my son
it's
rockies or whatever it doesn't matter
i miss that that's like the one thing i
i loved seeing was like snowy mountains
it's just getting to see your son just
that natural
beauty of the earth you know yeah i've
been seeing my kid i would like to see
my kid old you know like 30 40. like to
see him growing up would be cool
that's great what about you anthony oh
man i'd like first thing go to the sun
sunrise with my wife
and then i rent like a really fast car
dude cruise around like top speed at
different places for a little
go see like you know different
landscapes and stuff
and then i told dan this like
even though like i never able to see
perfect i still had some sight when i
was younger where i could like get
around in the day a little bit
and i never could see anything at night
once the lights off i don't there's
nothing at all and
i always wanted to like run around the
world at like night time like see what
it's like like being able to see while
the lights are kind of off you know like
that feeling and just like
the field of fireflies at night exactly
like look looking at the stars like a
winner
what does that call a telescope like to
the to the moon and [ __ ] like that oh
man like i look at the sky at night when
there's a full moon and i could see a
speck of light and i just like wonder
what the [ __ ] that looks like yeah
um
let me ask this question i know it's
gonna sound stupid at first i'll preface
that but
what do you think besides having vision
people with vision take most for granted
when it comes to sight
their sight is that does my question
make sense
yeah i mean obviously the answer is just
the ability to see but yeah um
the amount of independence i think that
you have that's a good answer to be able
to like
we're always having to wait on somebody
or something even if it's uber right
like yes i'm more independent with it
but i still have to wait for somebody i
still have to order that ride and i'm on
somebody else's time
so to be on just your own time and
grab your car keys and walk out the door
and leave when you want to leave just
say that would be the thing that i
definitely
took the most granted for
and missed the most of that independence
yeah i'd say freedom like and like
i know everyone has anxiety and stuff
but like the
the lack of anxiety that you'll have
from
being able to see if you were blind like
the extra anxiety you have to deal with
on a day-to-day basis just to get some
things done
it's like because you'll have a task and
you're like
okay for me like i gotta get my guitar
like pick my guitar up from the store or
something it's like [ __ ] now i gotta
figure out how i'm gonna get there how
i'm gonna get back
you know what's like how is this all
going to look and like figure out where
am i going to get dropped off at where's
the door going to be at exactly how am i
going to find my ride and get back home
yeah on that little [ __ ] man
and look at looking at beautiful women
too
miss that
uh thank you both for coming on this has
been an enlightening and uh really
interesting and fun episode
uh dan i asked you the question when you
were on here last time so anthem i asked
you this time advice you'd give to your
16 year old self
chill the [ __ ] out yeah that's i was
like so
also just being comfortable with myself
like trying like dude don't worry about
what everyone else thinks because
everyone else is so concerned about
themselves just the way you are like
worrying about like fitting in and all
that stuff it's like
just be more comfortable with who you
are like be comfortable in your own skin
because it's not like
it's not going anywhere you know i
remember
wise guy once told me he's like
dude you're blind and the world's not
waiting for you so just figure it out
yeah
well guys thank you both will you please
plug promote uh anything you'd like
again
yeah four bad eyes across the board
f-o-u-r um and then dan the man seen his
personal account
yeah uh just asf vision across the board
it's personal four bad eyes baby
honeydew y'all thank you
guys thank you so much for having me you
got it man thank you for being here as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you